Jake:看看那个快递群啊
Jake: Check the delivery group.
Jake:有的话就往里面发
Jake: If there is something, post it there.
Jake:mission complete一半我来拿
Jake: I'll take half of the mission complete.
Jake:充电宝上
Jake: On the power bank.
Jake:有快递吗
Jake: Any delivery?
Jake:好吧好的
Jake: Alright, okay.
Jake:谢斌竹你你那个充电宝给我充电
Jake: Xie Binzhu, give me your power bank to charge.
其他人：找不到了
Others: Can't find it.
Jake:你就在你旁
Jake: It's right next to you.
Jake:你就你我看
Jake: It's right, let me see.
Jake:找到了
Jake: Found it.
其他人：我以为你说黑的
Others: I thought you meant the black one.
Jake:来吧
Jake: Come on.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Jake:来
Jake: Come.
Jake:你的快递发一发呗
Jake: Send your delivery, okay?
Tasha: 发了
Tasha: Sent it.
Jake:快递发好了
Jake: Delivery sent.
Tasha: 快递
Tasha: Delivery.
Jake:嗯快递你可以发群里看他取不取
Jake: Yeah, you can post it in the group to see if he picks it up.
Jake:他要不取咱取他要取咱不取
Jake: If he doesn't, we pick it up. If he does, we don't.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Jake:你这是一气呵成
Jake: You did it all in one go.
Jake:早上我只把这一个眼镜放在这
Jake: This morning, I only put this one pair of glasses here.
Jake:因为你好像说要早上来戴
Jake: Because you said you wanted to wear it in the morning.
Jake:差一点现在才7:49
Jake: Almost, it's just 7:49 now.
Jake:只是他醒的比较早哈哈哈
Jake: He just woke up quite early, hahaha.
Jake:你昨天勾人呢
Jake: You were flirting yesterday.
Jake:你昨天是什么时候把眼镜放下去的
Jake: When did you put the glasses down yesterday?
Katrina: 昨天把眼镜给
Katrina: I gave the glasses yesterday.
Katrina: 昨天就是做了一会手工眼镜给了
Katrina: I was doing some crafts yesterday and gave the glasses.
Jake:完了记录在案呢
Jake: It's recorded.
Jake:完了
Jake: It's done.
Jake:什么
Jake: What?
Jake:啊没有没有
Jake: Ah, no, nothing.
Jake:就是我们我们不知道他这个眼镜下去
Jake: We just didn't know he brought these glasses down.
Jake:然后睡觉之前
Jake: Then before going to sleep,
Jake:嗯踢了一下发现是个眼镜
Jake: I kicked it and found out it was a pair of glasses.
Jake:然后就就就挺好还是导了
Jake: So, it's pretty good, still got it done.
Tasha: 噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun
Jake:修硕他不认识你
Jake: Shure doesn't know you.
Shure: 不认识什么
Shure: Doesn't know what?
Jake:他不认识你
Jake: He doesn't know you.
Jake:对他他不知道
Jake: Yeah, he doesn't know.
Jake:你叫什么
Jake: What's your name?
Jake:你叫什么呀
Shure: 我笑
Shure: I laugh.
Shure: 行不更名
Shure: I don't change my name.
Shure: 坐不改姓
Shure: I don't change my surname.
Jake:鄙人修公子
Jake: I am Mr. Shure.
Jake:半分钟讲电影
Jake: Explain the movie in 30 seconds.
Jake:什么呀这是半分钟讲电影吗
Jake: What? Is this explaining the movie in 30 seconds?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 一口气看完整部动漫
Shure: Watch the entire anime in one go.
Jake:早上好
Jake: Good morning.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Jake:你的眼镜好了
Jake: Your glasses are fixed.
Jake:我们跟你的眼镜奋战了一晚上
Jake: We battled with your glasses all night.
Jake:你的眼镜这根线好像有点问题
Jake: Seems like there's something wrong with this wire on your glasses.
Jake:我们也不知道咋回事
Jake: We have no idea what's going on.
Jake:那就只能战斗了
Jake: We'll just have to fight it out.
Jake:就传不上就重新再传呵呵
Jake: If it doesn't upload, we'll just re-upload it, haha.
Jake:哎我先给你删了吧
Jake: Hey, let me delete it first.
Jake:反正最后是导完了
Jake: Anyway, it got uploaded in the end.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:可能要重启一下
Jake: Maybe we need to restart.
Jake:不然他又不出那个小跳
Jake: Or it won't show that little jump.